[Musique]
quant à youtube heures payées par une
marque pour mettre en avant un produit
non je bois de l'eau en fête commun et
ont payé ça me pellegrino à 10000 20000
combien et aux cymbales les amis
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter des
anecdotes sur les opus pts qui n'empêche
pas une op espèces et quant à youtube
heures travail avec une marque pour
faire une vidéo sponsorisés voilages et
des anecdotes trop marrante avoir à
compter sur ça mais avant il faut que je
vous explique quelques trucs pour vous
puissiez comprendre les anecdotes c'est
bien comme ça ça me permet de casser
quelques fausses idées reçues et
d'apporter un peu plus de lumière et de
transparence sur ce sujet qui fait tant
par mediu tube aujourd'hui à aller
youtuber adore l'argent c'est bien connu
c'est une blague c'est vrai c'est une
blague c'est même quasiment tous les
youtube heures vous connaissez
aujourd'hui travaillent avec une régie
publicitaire cette régie va être chargé
de lui trouver des vidéos sponsorisées
affaire alors ça peut aller dans les
deux sens par exemple on a eu à el
ghalia cecos kingdom aux singes moore ya
kingdom qui veut mettre en avant ses
ventilateurs et leur budget ses 10000
euros dîner des deux vidéos qui peuvent
être cool là je réponds oui si j'ai une
idée est que il ya un truc cool à faire
autour des ventilateurs en l'occurrence
je réponds archi non autre scénario
possible est la régie j'ai découvert la
marque kingdom ils font des supers
ventilateur et j'aimerais bien faire une
vidéo autour de leurs produits contre un
peu de gym youtuber j'aime l'argent est
là la régie va contacter la marque et
leur proposer de faire une vidéo
collaboration exclusive ont de l'argent
pour mettre en avant leurs ventilateurs
voilà alors ce que j'ai dit ça peut
paraître évident et basique pour
certains qui ont fait école de commerce
mais pour tous les autres je vous assure
je croise plein de gens qui n'ont aucune
idée de comment ça se passe des croix
même des fois qu'on m'oublie jamais des
trucs en avant j'ai acheté une [ __ ] de
sam paix parce que j'adore la cnpb m'ont
pas payer payer moi si vous voulez un
jeu propre mais tout n'est pas forcément
du placement j'aurais pu être payée par
sap et pour mettre en avant sa
pellegrino par exemple mais c'est pas le
cas mais si c'était le cas j'aurais été
obligé de le préciser en haut de la
description et aussi de cocher la case
vous savez où il ya s'accaparer la celle
ci a pas ça sur une vidéo c'est que
normalement il contient pas de placement
de produit ou alors le youtuber est un
petit cachottier et il peut lui arriver
du malheur parce que tout ça c'est
contrôlé par le gouvernement ce qui fait
ça s'appelle alors de la publicité
déguisée et ça c'est puni par la loi
j'ai quasi finie je suis désolé c'est
hyper chiant chez dresser leur a apporté
c'est que quand elle est super fait du
deuil qu'une marque elle un droit de
regard sur ce que youtube heures a fait
c'est à dire que avant de mettre la
vidéo en ligne le
burns envoie pour qu'elle valait bien
tout ce qu'il ya dedans imaginove par
youtube heures par exemple un film une
blague très limites dans sa vidéo je
sais pas moi des propos racistes par
exemple pire truc la marque a droit de
dire ah bah nan là tu ta fiche avec nous
nous on cautionne pas que tu dises des
tout pareil alors ça dégage les amis la
première anecdote elle est géniale et
tout est ma faute la marque n'a rien
fait c'est moi qui ai verde mais j'étais
jeune est ce que cette vidéo dit quelque
chose à des gens parmi vous ça fait
presque trois ans déjà ça passe mais
pour ceux qui me suivaient à l'époque
j'avais mis cette vidéo en ligne + gyr
les supprimer et j'avais remis en ligne
plus tard je n'ai jamais expliqué
pourquoi aujourd'hui en 2018 je vais
résoudre ce mystère de vente aussi et
vous allez rire cette vidéo était
sponsorisé par disney infiniti qx 3.0 je
sais plus telle agence ou disney en
direct mais bref j'avais dit oui pour
faire une vidéo sur leur jeu bon jeu
j'avais mes raisons
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça c'est
papa 2015 c'était un peu un chien
vachement 6rd mulquin c'était un haut de
game les op clairement tout ce qu'ils
aient développé à chaque fois c'était de
la merde y'a pas de grosse vidéo
scénarisé trop une fetwa par un peu
peut-être sur ce crime et moi sur ma
chaise je savais pas faire ça à moi juge
je jouais et j'encaissais je tourne la
vidéo
pas très amusant ce qui s'y passe mais
c'est pas grave clément montrent la
vidéo il me dit luca c'est pas très
amusant ce qui se passe mais c'est pas
grave et il fait le montage regarde la
vidéo elle est pas ou font un pas se
mentir parce que bas à ce que j'avais
fait sur le jeu s'était pas ou feint
clairement on à voir la vidéo à disney
et on attend qui valide pour que je
puisse la mettre en ligne met 72 heures
validé mais 62
normalement une marque elle met entre 4
et 8 heures la vidéo elle est en ont
répertorié et avec 46 disney l'a regardé
46 fois avant de la valider ils ont
zoomé sur chaque pixel pour voir s'ils
avaient pas un truc de cash et raciste
ou comment ça se passe
bref il valide enfin la vidéo mais
petite douille l'art regarde une fois
avant la met en ligne et je me dis et si
je rajouter un petit effet mlg est là il
faut que j'ai gagné la course plus
marrant aulas sait quoi en effet mlg
c'est ça
c'est souvent utilisé comme un mec vient
de faire une action badass dans un jeu
jeudi à clément de rajouter ça il me
renvoie la vidéo mais je ne la refait
pas validé par disney non non non j'ai
pas envie d'attendre que 45 personnes de
chez disney la voix la vidéo et ça va
décaler tous mon planning moi j'avais
prévu de la met en ligne aujourd'hui
l'erreur il y a donc ceci dans la vidéo
que disney n'a pas vu un bernos copie je
mets la vidéo en ligne
et là je suis pris d'une fatigue mentale
je ne sais pas pourquoi le pire moment
de l'année pour faire une sieste
écoutez bien vraie histoire la seule
pièce que j'ai fait en 2015 c'était
celle ci y en a eu aucune août c'était
celle ci je m'allonge sur mon canapé et
je m'endors paisiblement pendant près de
deux heures
à mon réveil je vois que l'écran de mon
téléphone est allumé je le prends pour
voir ce qui se passe et l'a47 appels
manqués 68 nouveaux messages j'appelle
quelqu'un qui s'appelle laurent et qui
bosse pour la régie publicitaire qui
avait négocié la vidéo sponsorisés avec
disney et ses premiers mots furent les
suivants lucas on est mort pourquoi
laurent lucas hatami snoop dogg qui
fument dans la vidéo
ah mais ça c'est un effet mail j'ai
c'est pas ils n'ont pas validé sa disney
s'était pas dans la version que tu m'as
envoyé à yes je me sens mal vous
connaissez ce quiz 2015 face à ça il ya
une réaction tout à fait humaine est
tout à fait compréhensible h m'emballer
couillaud qui sont acceptés travailler
avec moi ils acceptent ça c'est mon
humour ça ok ils ont rien à dire je me
tape trois ans après pour avoir dit ça
laurent m'expliquer clairement au bout
du fil que si je ne supprime pas la
vidéo nous allons partir en procès car
ce que j'ai fait est parfaitement
illégal je voulais dire la marque doit
valider la vidéo avant qu'elles soient
mises en ligne c'est comme ça la marque
achète une pub en vrai quand elle quand
elle fait une op avec toi tu peux pas la
berner comme ça c'est pas possible on
reçoit une lettre des avocats de disney
est ce que quelque chose de pire peut
arriver disney qui t'envoient ses
avocats disney disney j'étais le plus
gros coup de pression de toute ma vie
que je supprime alors la vidéo disney au
final on accepter qu'on remette la vidéo
en ligne sans l'effet mlg voilà est-ce
que parce que j'étais en posture pour
négocier
pas du tout j'ai vraiment baissé mon
pantalon j'ai dit ok disney on y va la
vidéo est toujours en ligne vous pouvez
aller la voir vous verrez à quel point
elle est d'une qualité incroyable l'une
des plus belles de respect de tous
youtube cette vidéo à merde ça c'était
la plus grosse anecdotes maintenant j'ai
quelques trucs un peu plus subtil mais
qui sont très amusants une fois avec
cyprien
devait faire une vidéo sur cyprien
gaming pour le jeu si ce n'est une
finity décidément ça n'arrête pas
vraiment qu'il n'existe plus ce jeu plus
tard c'était une vidéo gameplay
traditionnel comme y en a des tas sur
youtube et souvent fait qu'on a tourné
une vidéo à l'époque ce spleen gaming
pour une marque il ya des gens de la
marque qui étaient en studio avec nous
et nous faisait un petit brief avant si
vous mettez un truc en avant c'est
plutôt ça parlait pas de ça à l'époque
c'était pas comme maintenant allez voir
qu'elle comprenait pas qu'il faille nous
laisser faire un peu ce qu'on veut pour
que la vidéo soit cool et que ça donne
envie de jouer au jeu dans leur intérêt
comme dans le nôtre en fait ce jour là
ils nous ont imposés non pas de parler
de certaines choses et nous ont imposé
des costumes de fuck bras ça peut être
drôle après tout puisque les costumes
sont un peu style et c'est marrant
comme vous pouvez le voir il n'y avait
plus aucune dignité dans nos corps tous
s'étaient envolés et la grosse blague
mec c'est que quand on avait mis les
costumes on avait tapé de barde ouf
parce qu'on ressemble à un remake thema
agro mondiale à un mauvais tapis quoique
j'aie sur le corps on commence à tourner
la vidéo rigole tout sur les costumes
parce qu'on a des dégaines pas possible
hélas les les mecs de lagence nous
disent ah non non nous attaquons prix
vous pouvez pas dire du mal des costumes
mais en fait on les met sur vous pour
aucun enfant derrière frère on dirait
que tu as parade wright tu me la met sur
le corps maintenant tu vas me laisser
rigoler de ses costumes de merde mon
gars c'est fou la marque nous avait
obligés à ne pas nous moquer des
costumes dans la vidéo alors déjà on
aurait pu enfoncer ce costume
il en aurait vendu 4 et ensuite c'était
une opé spe pour le jeu les costumes là
c'est un traquenard
bref un cauchemar mais au final ça
valait le coup parce que j'ai vu c'est
que rien dans cette tenue et ça ça n'a
pas de prix
autre anecdote d'une grosse galère qu'on
est à excipe on a travaillé vraiment
dans le vent c'est horrible c'était pour
le jeu vous savez ce que je vais dire
encore lui quelle était cette fois on
s'est dit bon les vidéos gameplay ça
marche pas cette fois on va trouver un
concept une idée cool et on va faire une
vraie vidéo sympa avec de la prod et où
on va créer une histoire entre les
persos pendant une partie de disney
infiniti comme si à chaque fois que tu
retires et de figurines ou temps posé
une sur le socle là elle se parler entre
elles cyprien écrit la vidéo parce qu'à
l'époque moi j'écrivais rien du tout sur
la chaîne pour l'heure ce tournage donc
on devait se peindre le visage en verre
pour ensuite juste à voir nos bouchers
les caler sur les persos en fait sur les
figurines john montre la vidéo c'est
celui qui faisait tous les montages des
supras gaming à l'époque on l'envoie
disney et trouve ça très drôle il valide
mais la vidéo n'est jamais sorti
pourquoi parce que quand disney france
l'a validé ils l'ont envoyée à disney
états unis mais disney tats-unis non à m
les etats-unis ont dit mais vous n'avez
pas le droit de faire parler les persos
de marvel dans la vidéo parce que oui on
avait mis nos bouches sur l'eau qui lie
sur thor sur spider man et tout et on
n'a pas le droit de les faire parler en
fait et les faire dire ce qu'on veut
sauf que si on avait su au début aurait
pas eu de problème mais on a su une fois
qu'on avait tous fait la vidéo elle
était prête à sortir au moment où je
tourne la gelée pas la vidéo mais je
vais la retrouver et petites énigmes
sont mal à regarder ensemble c'est parti
regardez ce que j'ai sur ma boite mail
john m'a envoyé une petite pastille de
cette vidéo en fait on n'a pas la vidéo
entièrement à une version où il a bougé
les bouches de deux manières différentes
et en fait disney devait choisir la
manière qu'ils préféraient mais comme
vous savez au final ils en ont préféré
aucune
clip disney infiniti là on ressort la
beauce mec ça ça date de 2013 ya cinq
ans ne soyez donc pas surpris si
l'humour n'est pas fou et si mon jeu
d'acteur n'est pas fou non plus c'est
parti il est pas mal béjart qu'elle a le
style d'un guerrier pas mal il a d
annuler par contre il n'ya pas de il n'a
pas de patron non ok ça commence tiens
tu es nouveau tu es aussi oui moi aussi
je veux tu arrives dans cgt pas de vrai
est ce que j'ai essayé de faire une voie
de renault est ce que c'est ça j'essaie
de faire là c'est ce que robert patrick
second je suis en train de me faire
engueuler par un mec qui vole grâce à
des élans plastiques dans le dos et ça
et moi par un mec qui joue encore avec
un bâton comme quand j'avais 6 ans quoi
[Musique]
c'est être bien qu'ils soient jamais
sortir salut black widow je m'élance
vers 3 pour pour savoir si
éventuellement tu aimerais se sortir
avec moi un vrai quoi ce soir commence
par mettre autre chose qu'un vulgaire
pyjama et on verra peut-être ça c'est la
bataille de 2013 mon pote web à marie et
les gains mais en attendant elle je suis
sûr que dans cette position lln crampes
aux bras et ça c'est pas mal après ce
passage là ou alors je ne suis pas du
tout objectif
loki mon frère revient avec moi à ce
garde ne pourront régner ensemble sur ce
magnifique royaume
tu as eu le marteau et moi le bâton
temps tu comprend deux mois depuis je
suis gamin mais elle est très bien ton
bâton tu peux faire plein de trucs avec
un peu drôle
voilà c'est le vieux dos qui n'est
jamais sorti et du coup je le sors cinq
ans après en ouest est pas mal pour les
pommes franchement je suis que les gens
auraient bien aimé peut-être me
trompe-je l anecdote sur la meilleure au
pays que j'ai fait à l'heure actuelle
sur la chaîne s'était overture battle un
clip clash entre les persos dover woods
c'était génial tout le processus créatif
qui a eu pour arriver à ce résultat
c'était très long c'était des mois et
des mois de travail ya vraiment beaucoup
de gens qui ont bossé là dessus et ont
tout donné pour atteindre un tel
résultat et je trouve autant de cette
opé le script est écrit on le fait
valider à bizarre bizarre france nous
dit c'est génial n'y a pas de soucis
alors nous on enregistre la musique
alors non tourner le clip l'an nous
remonte le clip et a beaucoup d'effets
spéciaux donc ça mais deux mois je crois
d'été spéciaux à faire et là on a une
version finale est talonné sesia
couleurs sont michael meeks et tout est
parfait mais laïque ou ya un moment
donné dans la version actuelle du clip
n'a tout dit
mais j'ai juste eu mal au crâne j'ai
payé ma tournée tu veux 100 mg de la
version originale elle ne disait pas ça
elle disait chirac et j'ai juste eu mal
au crâne dû payer ma tournée qui veut un
doliprane
c'est pour ça que quand elle dit 100 mg
s'élève ne suis pas du tout le mot mais
on avait tout fait et on a dû modifier
sa mecque le som intégral n'a tout elle
a dû retourner en studio pour
enregistrer la phrase on adule a remixé
l'intégrer occupe ça a retardé la sortie
de la vidéo que j'étais dégoûté c'est
des petits trucs mais vous savez pas
comme c'est horrible quand ça tombe à la
dernière minute en fait surtout sait
tous qu'on aurait pu éviter enfin bon
bref au final la vidéo vous a quand même
hyper plus à la même marché à
l'international il ya des américains qui
l'ont vu des anglais bref toute la
communauté envers lucho mondiale a
entendu parler de cette vidéo
du coup je suis trop content puisque
c'est ce que je voulais surtout aux
anciennes vidéos sté faire kiffer les
joueurs nouvelle route sera un beau
projet comme ça je suis très content
voilà les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo j'espère que ces petites anecdotes
concernant ce que j'ai pu faire avec des
marques sont fait marrer oui j'ai fait
de la merde des fois et alors mais à
côté de ça il ya des trucs bien quand
même
j'espère aussi avoir bien éclairer votre
lanterne sur ce sujet parce qu'il ya une
paranoïa générale avec les placements de
produits et où il ya des gens qui
diabolise ça alors franchement
maintenant tout est clairement dit en
plus sur youtube les gens ils assument
ils disent voilà c'est sponso par bidule
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il faut aimer
à tout prix on a le droit trouvait que
la vidéo et de la mer des fois c'est
vraiment de la merde et c'est scandaleux
on tient bon d'accord je suis premier
rideau mais des fois y'a vraiment des
trucs cool et je comprends pas que les
gens s'énervent si vous avez des
questions en commentaire hésitez pas je
trouve que c'est intéressant je
répondrais peut-être à quelques-uns je
vous fais plein de bisous julia tu es
dans une prochaine vidéo puis j'espère
que ce sera quand même été un peu
intéressant pour vous voilà c'est bon
j'aime ça ça c'est mon gel voilà moi
l'argent super
[Musique]
et
ah oui